[Música]
la curva de contagio en china cede y la
vida en europa continúa con relativa
normalidad la alfombra roja se despliega
para el festival de cine de berlín en
milán se juega un partido de fútbol
entre atalanta y el valencia
[Música]
paralelamente en irán se llevan a cabo
elecciones legislativas
y latinas que todo el que está
interesado en defender los intereses
nacionales debe participar en las
elecciones el virus se esparce
rápidamente entre el 20 y el 29 de
febrero los casos en italia explotan
pasa de tener tres casos a superar los
1100 el país declara la alerta y en un
esfuerzo por contener el brote más
grande en europa autoridades de la
región de lombardía emiten una lista de
ciudades y pueblos que entran en un
bloqueo completo
otro país que preocupa es irán los casos
así siguen el mismo ritmo que italia y
en pocos días superan los mismos incluso
el viceministro de salud
está positivo yo también me contagié de
coronavirus he tenido fiebre desde
anoche en mi examen preliminar resultó
positivo cerca de la medianoche me aislé
desde ese momento
mientras la situación en italia irán se
complica en eeuu el presidente de trump
continúa minimizando la peligrosidad del
virus because of wheat debido a todo lo
que hemos hecho el riesgo para el pueblo
estadounidense sigue siendo muy bajo
tres días después de estas declaraciones
eeuu reporta la primera muerte debida al
virus
[Música]
el virus desembarca en latinoamérica
comenzó si el paciente llegó a
sintomático sin fiebre o tos o gripe se
quedó el viernes y sábado y el domingo
tuvo una reunión con su familia para su
regreso 2 el lunes buscó una unidad
médica
también se reporta la primera muerte es
lamentable tener que informarles que el
día de hoy ha fallecido
nuestra primera paciente que fue
diagnosticada por coronavirus en el
ecuador
y la economía empieza a sentir los
efectos de la crisis la reserva federal
de eeuu recortan las tasas de interés
pese al esfuerzo de las autoridades en
los días siguientes las principales
bolsas del mundo se hunde
[Música]
el 8 de marzo dos eventos paralelos
suceden en europa mientras en españa se
lleva a cabo una multitudinaria
celebración del 'día internacional de la
mujer' el primer ministro de italia
giuseppe conte firma un decreto que pone
en cuarentena parte del norte de italia
lo que afecta a unas 10 millones de
personas el documento se filtra horas
antes del anuncio oficial y miles de
ciudadanos empiezan a regresar a sus
hogares generalmente en el sur agravando
de esta manera la crisis
sólo un día después del anuncio la
situación se sale de control en italia
la restricción de cuarentena en el norte
se extiende a todo el país 60 millones
de personas deberán permanecer en sus
hogares noches de edad
ya no habrá una zona roja no habrá una
zona 1 o 2 de la península será italia
italia como zona protegida un italia y
una protesta el 11 de marzo la o&m se
hace un anuncio esperado voz bailar ming
lado ms ha estado evaluando este brote
permanentemente y estamos profundamente
preocupados tanto por los alarmantes
niveles de propagación y gravedad como
por los niveles de inacción y por lo
tanto hemos determinado que el kobe 19
se puede caracterizar como una panera
list als pandemic tras el anuncio de la
o ms eeuu declara el estado de
emergencia nacional y francia comienza
la batalla contra el virus en nuestras
fronteras con países no europeos
continuarán cerradas hasta nuevo aviso
entonces desplegaremos todos los medios
necesarios para proteger a la población
de ceder a la protección la potencia
el mundo entra en confinamiento la
mayoría de los países imponen
restricciones de movilidad e implementan
cuarentenas generalizadas
[Música]
imágenes de calles vacías en las
metrópolis más pobladas comienzan a ser
frecuentes
italia y españa- viven los días más
duros de la pandemia los hospitales se
saturan y las funerarias no dan abasto
en italia los camiones del ejército
tienen que ayudar a transportar los
cuerpos
el 24 de marzo de 2020 la llama olímpica
se apaga
propuse pues ponerlos por un año y el
presidente va que estuvo 100% de acuerdo
también acordamos que celebraremos los
juegos olímpicos y paralímpicos en el
verano de 2021 a más tardar hack para
send el primer ministro de reino unido
boris johnson se convierte en el primer
líder mundial en dar positivo los
superaremos y la forma en que vamos a
hacerlo es claro aplicando las medidas
de las que han escuchado tanto y entre
más efectivamente las compramos más
rápido a nuestro país saldrá de la
pandemia y más rápido nos recuperaremos
rescate tras un mes de severa crisis en
europa los casos empiezan a disminuir en
los primeros días de abril
las imágenes de agradecimiento al
personal sanitario desde los balcones
inundan las redes sociales y la pandemia
cambia de epicentro
[Aplausos]